all right thanks everyone um excited to
have such a great group here for our
afternoon talks um it's really lovely to
see so many people excited and also able
to find uh whatever this room is called
qus Quicks Shucks I've heard a few
things anyway congratulations on finding
it so excited to introduce you to our
speaker uh vessel Sanka um and uh yeah
I'll let him kick off with his
presentation about llms in literary
features
thank you all um yeah welcome uh this is
going to be don't judge a book by its C
discover and using llm created data sets
to train models that detect literary
features I'm vessel Sanka I'm a data
scientist at bang and on the side I've
written a couple of children's books and
uh in my free time I fix antique
typewriters um I work for Bang uh
company started in 20133 and a part of
the organization biblion and all of the
Dutch people in the in this room will
recognize biblion because they prep all
the books for the libraries in the
Netherlands so if you recognize that
classic library book it's done by
biblion and that's not the only thing
they do uh because they also need a lot
of metadata for that like uh who's the
author who wrote the book and What's the
title of the book and it used to be the
case that that kind of data was just
written down by a person and then
entered into a database and uh bang has
automated all that that's the metadata
generation here and then we also went
further than that with uh text analysis
because what we do is not just provide
metadata for M bibl but we also uh
provide recommendation systems for Dutch
libraries and um very specifically what
we do is uh we analyze the text and the
contents of a book so that we make a
recommendation not just based on the
popularity of a book but actually what's
inside of it um and that creates a much
better recommendation we think um
because uh when you read a book it has a
very specific style or it's funny or
it's dark or it's very poetic or down to
earth and uh if you can recommend a book
that's based on those kind of features
it will give you much better
recommendation than just saying like oh
you like sci-fi here's the other sci-fi
book that's currently really popular and
then maybe it will be like a ya romance
novel or like a Game of Thrones kind of
Novel and it's just very different
stylistically um so yeah let's look at
some recommendations uh in the wild as
they are currently done by large
companies and then look at how we
approach the same subject um so let's uh
start with a large online book seller in
the Netherlands uh without naming any
names um I just I just put in like what
if what if I want to buy Bu The Game of
Thrones uh book box set uh books one
through five and then you get just like
with many companies you get
a buyers or frequently bought together
and then you get this list which I
thought was a pretty interesting list um
mostly because you see the same product
uh slightly more expensive version
actually and also the other
recommendation is Fire and Blood which
is probably a great recommendation if
you're very into gim thron but then the
third one is another iron blood except
it's more expensive and it takes longer
to get to your house
um although it's a bit of a false
comparison because this is not a true
recommendation system and I also tried
it for like an RGB keyboard and then
they immediately think like oh do you
want a high performance Mouse met do you
want an extra Headphone set so like
generally they're really good but for
books it's sometimes like not quite on
the Mark um for Goodreads though because
good reads of course is much more
focused fed on actual like reviews and
recommendations and like what to read
next and so I looked at the well not the
whole box set but just this time just
the first book uh Game of Thrones um and
I looked at uh what readers also
enjoyed and then uh the first four
results were these um and I thought it
was quite interesting because like some
of these are quite similar like The
Hobbit but even with the Hobbit You
could argue that uh like The Hobbit is
stylistically extremely different and
it's it's a book from 1937 it's
technically meant for children um and
and not the first thing I would
necessarily recommend after reading Game
of Thrones uh the second one is actually
Game of Thrones but this is a comic book
uh and I thought that it was um like
sure probably all the people who've read
this comic book will have read Game of
Thrones and liked it uh but I don't know
if that's necessarily the measure we
want to go by I thought that the pie
chart would look a little a little bit
like this um and um yeah I wasn't sure
if I would put it on the second spot for
readers also enjoyed there's Harry
Potter which is just like lots of people
probably gave that five stars and also
gave Game of Thrones five stars and then
there's the Fellowship of the Ring
except it's the art of The Fellowship of
the Ring um which uh maybe I don't know
I would recommend either the Normal book
or maybe an art book about Game of
Thrones um and this just shows that cor
correlation is not necessarily caus
which
hopefully that's okay that's
okay um correlation is not necessarily
causation because lots of people will
have loved Harry Potter and will also
have loved Game of Thrones but when you
read Harry Potter and you say to someone
I really like this no one will go oh my
God their next read should definitely be
Game of Thrones and the other way around
as well
um
yes and so I also asked CH GPT because
you know you you you kind of have to uh
and I knew that there were going to be
some tough questions if I didn't include
this so I said that I really enjoyed a
night of the S gness which is uh Game of
Thrones adjacent book and then um it
actually recommended uh some books to me
and what I thought was really
interesting that was that it would
immediately went to themes so like
medieval fantasy and chivalry and
intricate intricate political Intrigue
which is indeed what the book is about
um but then you can see that ch PT also
like starts on that content based or at
least it it wants to get closer rather
than just uh taking correlations uh and
this is a really nice uh list of um
recommendations all these books I think
match the first book pretty closely um
but there are a few disadvantages
because I think these are great
recommendations if you haven't read any
fantasy in the last like 10 to 20 years
um because these are like the most
popular fantasy series of the moments
maybe not the first lot trilogy but it's
still pretty big um yeah a couple of
disadvantages from asking chat GPT is
that of course first of all it doesn't
do any information from 2021 and before
uh no and after um so I hope that you
don't read too much because any new book
will have to wait like uh you have to
wait two years before it can be
recommended and also specifically our
company bang is for the Dutch library
system and that means that we focus on
Dutch books
and um despite chpt understanding the
Dutch language pretty well uh the Dutch
book database in chpt is more lacking
than the English one and then on top of
that we also do a lot with children's
books and with children's books it adds
another layer of complexion it becomes
even more difficult for C GPT to know
what you're talking about and stuff like
that and maybe most important of all is
that um as you can see these are super
popular book series and I've noticed
that it goes in a bit of a popularity
cycle like if you put any of these
series into the uh yeah into your prompt
like oh yeah that was a really good
series what about these then you you
kind of get very similar and
overlapping uh recommendations well what
you really want is to go like a little
bit more obscure probably because the
well-known series you've already read
them or you've at least heard of them um
and then to illustrate that Dutch
children's books become a little less
easy I I am a Dutch children's book
writer and I wrote olant so I thought
I'd ask like what if what if I pop in my
own book and see what it does and so I
asked uh I I really like the memory of
an elephant do you have some suggestions
based on that and it says the memory of
an elephant by the author Alex PL which
is not me and also I Googled him and he
did not write a book with the same name
and then it's talking about like the
humoristic Memoir and standup comedy and
like personal anecdotes and I thought
well I mean let's let's try and see if
if if we can write it on the on the
right path and I'm like no no no written
written by vessel sanska and I says oh
of course uh that book you will
definitely love like humoristic and
personal anecdotes and then it says
pessimism you can learn
and I know the title is you can't judge
a book by its cover but if you see this
title and if you see this
cover there's a slight chance that this
won't be the perfect book The Perfect
recommendation of course would have been
my other
book but in case you're interested in
like not liter literarure for
six-year-olds then maybe we should uh
take some different things so what what
do we read next um and and just let's
let's take a look at at a couple things
so we can look at the author of course
and we can look at the
cover um so let's start with the author
it's I mean sometimes it works really
well like if you like one book by George
are our Martin you'll probably like all
of them because they're all basically
the same but for example if you are a
fan of the Beloved children's book
series Harry Potter then like it won't
it won't translate really well to books
that this author wrote next which are
completely different genre it's for a
completely different age group uh let
alone anything that you read on a
Twitter feed um so let's let's let's
scrap the author because also if it's a
first novel by an author like then
you'll never read anything new
let's look at the cover and the talk
title is don't judge a book by its cover
uh but you can judge a book a little bit
by its cover like if you see this you'll
know you know that it's a fancy book and
you know it's going to be like
action-packed and it's probably not
going to pass the back Dell test and um
yeah but if if you if you zoom in a
little bit because just knowing those
things are like might not be enough for
you to think oh yeah I really want to
read this book and I know what this book
is going to be about so you look closely
at the at the cover and you see you need
to be a little bit of a history buff for
this but you see like men in uniforms
and there's a there's a rifle here in
the bottom and these uniforms are of
like American Civil War soldiers which
is strange because this book is about
like fantasy Vikings um so you can't
really judge a book by its cover because
it's not it's not an accurac and
accurate representation of what's going
to be inside of it let alone whether
you'll like it you can say I would like
an action-packed fantasy novel but then
that can still go a lot of different
ways um so maybe reviews reviews are
pretty good uh way of course to see
whether you'll like a book um we
personally don't use those because they
add a subjective layer um like we are
mostly interested in what's inside of
the book the actual content the text of
the book and
review um like if you find a reviewer
that has the exact same taste as you
that's great but if you don't then a
review can go either way and you still
won't really know uh whether you will
like this book you'll only know if this
other person liked the book so then we
end up with the blurp which is like the
text on the back of a book and the text
itself and um at first we're going to
talk about the blur because that's what
we tried first to see if we can get
enough information out of the
blur um to see what the whole book is
about and whether we'll like it and
stuff
um so let's uh let's let's look at a
blurp in a sleepy Village in the Shire
young photo baggin find themselves faced
with an immense task as the ring is
entrusted to his care he must leave his
home and make a perilous journey across
the Realms of Middle Earth through the
crack of Doom deep inside the
territories of the dark lord well you
can you can get quite a lot out of this
you can see that it's probably going to
be a fancy novel again um and there's
like perilous journey and the crack of
Doom and dark lord and all of these kind
of words will give you some sort of idea
of what this book is going to be about
um but there are some small downsides to
uh using uh blur which is that uh first
of all it's not written by the author
it's written by the publisher and a
publisher wants to sell books not
necessarily like tell you whether you
will like it because the publisher wants
you to think that you will always like
this book like 100% of the time the
publisher thinks that you should buy
this book um and also regularly it's
absent or sometimes it has only like
quotes and reviews of like other famous
writers and then the worst of those is
you'll love this book if you love this
other book and there's nothing that
messes with our models as much as like
naming other book titles in uh on a book
that's not that specific book um but we
still tried it and what we did was you
take the blurp and we put it in a bar
classifier or like we we fine-tuned that
and U we also had human labels uh human
annotated labels on the whole book
level um that would say like what the
style was of the book and whether it was
funny and whether it was dark or sad or
stuff like that
um and um yeah that worked reasonably
well um but like I said it the it was it
just wasn't quite Rich enough uh the
information on the back of a book is
just so much less information than you
get throughout the whole book um that uh
we wanted to see if we could go not just
to a blurp level representation but an
actual book level representation
because in the book uh itself there's
obviously much more um yeah it's much
richer um so we went to text it's
actually written by the author uh for
now and hopefully for a long time um and
it contains lots of information where
you can get a lot of different kind of
um yeah where you can get a lot of
different information out of it uh text
analysis it is however quite difficult
to parse and that's where we get to llms
because that's what what this talk is
partially about
um llms have a couple of U downside and
upsides some of the cons are that uh we
are simply not allowed to send books to
third parties so we can't just send a
whole book uh to a place oh by the way
we used blurbs for be rather than the
whole text because the text was too long
it simply didn't fit in the model and
that's why we had to resort to something
smaller um yeah but llms can technically
take a lot more information uh sadly
we're not allowed to send the whole
books to third parties so that was out
we could just send the book and say like
what style is this um and also we kind
of want to minimize our dependency on
like Mega corporations um there's not
that much downtime but like still pretty
bad if you just put it into pipeline if
you if you have your pipeline you just
send the whole book to GPT or whatever
and you get it and you get back this
book is this kind of style and this kind
of sadness and this kind of funny um
yeah anytime it goes down that's quite a
problem also it's not as established as
of yet so the cost might still differ
and um you don't want to completely
integrate it into your pipeline and then
after a couple months realize like oh
they upped the price and they made it 10
fold of what it is now um and lastly
quality so obviously the quality of GPT
is really high or any other llm is also
really high but GPT specifically um ande
equality will constantly improve with
every like new model but maybe you've
noticed that over the first few days and
months that c GPT was out the quality
would actually like differ a bit and
maybe get a little bit worse suddenly
you couldn't uh Google or you shouldn't
you couldn't ask it for like violent
things or for things related to sex or
other things that were not as Advertiser
friendly or not as family friendly um
and of course in novels you have a lot
of those those kind of things that
aren't necessarily suited for work or
suited for advertisers um there's a
other Pro though it's very powerful so
we still wanted to work our way around
this um and that's what we did we wanted
to create something that we didn't have
to put GPT in the pipeline but we still
wanted to make use of its power so we
didn't send a whole book to it but maybe
a part of it so what we did was we
started with a
book and we took five fragments out of
it and those fragments are not the book
anymore and you can like maximum of 100
or 150 words and those we are actually
allowed to send so we send those to an
LM and we asked the llm can you rate
these fragments on uh 10 different axes
is it poetic is it dark is it funny and
some
other um what we did then was uh we
trained 10 Robert models uh Robert is a
Bert version uh but specifically for the
Dutch language because that's yeah a big
problem in for our whole company like
every llm is really good until you try
it on Dutch and then it becomes
significantly less good Robert's really
quite uh good at it and we fine-tune
those models on the different axes so we
made 10 different
models then we split up uh a book in x
amount of fragments which which in total
were the full
book um so it could be 100 fragments or
200 fragments or however long the book
was um and what we did then was we uh
had those 10 different robot models
annotate every single fragment so that
you got back to a full book
representation so we started at the book
we couldn't send it to an llm but we did
want an llm to annotate it and if you
look here then you kind of had your
whole book annotated by an llm without
sending the whole text away to that llm
so keeping everything in house and we
did just with as with the blurps we do
have uh human anotated book
representations there's a team of
annotators that read the book and then
say like we think it's this amount of
funny and this amount of poetic in this
amount of whatever and uh we trained
another model Noe that's the wrong way
we trained another model uh an lstm uh
with the training data the Robert
annotated book representations and as
evaluate as labels human annotated book
representations and then we didn't just
use the axes uh that we asked for check
GPT but we combined them into uh style
or humor or something um so that you
could have like an axis of how
stylistically complex this is how yeah
um yeah and that uh that was how we we
created the pipeline so you can see that
we still use the power of an llm without
sending anything there and uh we end up
with um well hopefully the same kind of
results that we would have gotten if we
had sent it to an llm
um so the results and this is a little
bit disappointing but they're very
difficult to measure um because um yeah
uh the evaluation sets are mostly based
on the blurp representations rather than
the full book representations so we're
still working on that but as far as we
can see currently is that these this new
uh pipeline is about just as good as the
blur level level representation with the
interesting thing uh that this model has
only been developed for like a couple
months while this blurp level level
representation has been in the work for
years and has been fine-tuned to death
so this does have the potential to be a
lot better um yeah especially as new
versions of GPT or other llms come out
and maybe uh models that are more
focused on the Dutch
language uh and we heard that uh GPT 4
for example doesn't hallucinate that
Alex PL wrote my book and like as soon
as you get to those things then well
everything becomes a lot um yeah a lot
more accurate and
precise um so the advantages of this new
approach is that we're not reliant on C
GPT or any other
llm um the data is kept inhouse which is
uh like we're legally obled and also for
lots of companies very important because
pretty much every company of course has
some data that they don't want to send
away oh this is a a way you can do it
and with every new version of an llm uh
we can create a new data set just plug
it into uh the pipeline that we have let
it create a new data set and with that
data set we can train our own new models
uh and hopefully that will only improve
um yeah improve our own models and thus
improve how accurate we are with style
and stuff because more better data means
more content based recommendations uh
not just saying this is popular but
rather you'll you love the style of this
book The funniness or the sadness or how
How It Was Written and well then you
might love another specific book as
well and that's it thank you so
much